>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Mari Nakahara: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining
today's program,
discussion by there Washington area
authors, so-called "Bonsai Trio,"
[laughter] Ann McClellan,
Sandra Moore, and Stephen Voss.
And I think everybody has
already gotten the book,
but I don't see many
books on your hand.
[Laughter] So for sale even after
the lecture, so please get it.
If you haven't, no worries.
My name is Mari Nakahara.
I'm a curator for the
Architecture Design and Engineering
at the Library's Prints
and Photograph Division.
I also serve as a coordinator
for today's program;
and this program is one of the 2017
National Cherry Blossom Festival,
co-hosted by the Library's Prints
and Photographs and Agent divisions.
Library has been participating in
the National Cherry Blossom Festival
from 2012, when we celebrated
the hundredth anniversary
of the Cherry Blossom Tree Gift from
the city of Tokyo to Washington,
D.C. And I decided to
continue hosting events
and programs coinciding with the
National Cherry Blossom Festival
every spring, even if the
scale is much smaller.
This is my effort to pursue
one of the Library's goals
of providing a general understanding
of American culture, intellectual
and social life, and of
other peoples and nations.
I'm also hoping that these events
and programs will, in the future,
inspire greater interest in Japanese
culture, the US-Japan relationship,
and also the Library's diverse
collections in the general public,
including K through 12 students.
We have a saying in Japan, "[Speaks
Japanese]," which means that,
"Something will blossom
if we are persistent."
This is another reason that I
continue these events and programs.
Here you will see on
the [inaudible],
one of my favorite collections
related to cherry blossoms,
"Eleven Varieties of the Cherry
Blossom Trees," sent from the city
of Tokyo to Washington, DC in 1912.
These are facsimile copies,
but the originals are held
at the Library's Prints
and Photographs Division.
Today, Stephen Voss is going
to donate six photographs
of bonsai trees, two of
which are shown here --
that's why I asked you
to move to the left side,
as well as a photograph of our new
Library of Congress, Dr. Hayden.
They will be added to the Prints
and Photographs collection.
Thank you, Stephen.
[Laughter] Many people
may think that Library
of Congress collections are not open
to the public, which is not true.
We welcome everybody if
they are 16 years or older,
with [inaudible] readers card.
The Library's Young Readers
Center is open to the public,
but much younger generations, where
our children are able to read books
like one by today's speaker, Sandra.
[Laughter] They host reading
programs periodically.
I host a Japanese Culture Day
there every spring as part
of the cherry blossom celebrations.
What I introduce now is a little
bit of the tip of the iceberg
of the Library's collections
and activities.
I would strongly recommend you
explore the Library's collections
via our website first,
and visit the Library.
Ann McClellan is one of our
patrons who uses the Library
of Congress collection frequently.
She will show a few Library
items in her presentation today.
In 2014, she kindly
accepted our favor to talk
about her cherry blossom
book at the Library,
which is also for sale today.
Today she returns to speak
about 53 bonsai trees Japan gave
as a bicentennial gift to
the United States in 1976;
and will also moderate
the panel discussion.
Well, I should stop now and
give the microphone to Ann.
Thank you again for joining today,
and I hope you enjoy the program
and the lecture, and leave
here with a great inspiration.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ann McClellan: Thank you, Mari.
It's really a pleasure
to be here, a thrill.
And as Mari said, I have a
frequent flyer here at the Library
of Congress, and it's wonderful to
be back and share what I've learned.
What we'll do today is I'll give
an overview, because the book
that I wrote, "Bonsai and Penjing:
Ambassadors of Peace and Beauty,"
that's this one, is an overview
of the collection of bonsai
at the National Arboretum.
And then Sandra Moore will talk
about one of the trees there.
And then Stephen Voss will
talk about his experience
as a photographer of the bonsai.
And then I'll wrap it up talking
about some of the other collections,
and then we'll go to
questions and answers.
So without further
adieu, let's get started.
And just to start things off,
here's an image from the Prints
and Photographs collection, which
I dearly love because this was --
it's a woodblock print from
1861, less than ten years
after Commodore Perry opened
Japan to trade with the West.
And there is an American merchant
admiring a cherry blossom tree
that's in a bonsai
form, a small tree.
So it's everything all in
one picture that I love.
And it's a foretelling, actually, of
the gift from Japan, first of all,
of the cherry blossom trees in 1912,
and then the bicentennial
gift of bonsai in 1976.
So before we get any
further, what is a bonsai?
A bonsai, it can be -- the word
"bonsai" can apply to a small tree
in a pot from anywhere in the world.
You could have a bonsai from Brazil.
The reason that the museum is called
the Museum of Bonsai and Penjing is
that there are Chinese versions.
And the original examples
were from China.
That's something -- an art form
that the Chinese have been pursuing
for 1,000 years, maybe more.
And the word "pensai,"
"Penjing,", "bonsai,"
they all mean "tree in a pot."
So what happened was that --
so what it is, is the idea of
experiencing a tree small-sized.
If you think about it, in the world,
in nature, we're usually smaller
than the trees that we see.
So there's not ever a point where
you can experience the whole thing
at one view; you have
to look up and down,
or left and right, or something.
But a bonsai, you can
get in one fell look.
The other thing that it does
is it provides the illusion
of old, of ancient.
And I chose this example because
I think it really shows that.
It's a Japanese white pine, and it
comes from the island of Miyajima.
And can't you just see
how it's sort of been --
it gives the illusion of
having been, you know,
leaning into the winds off
the water, you know, for eons,
with that thick trunk
and the chunky bark?
So in my mind, what this is,
it's a way of expressing --
of experiencing, you
know, almost a once upon
at time in the Western idea.
So it's a way of experiencing a time
before, and it gives you a bridge
to the world that's outside of
your daily concerns, that takes you
out of your -- you know, sort
of the daily grind, if you will.
This tree has been in
training since 1879.
And what we mean by "in training"
is at some point, someone, a person,
chose that tree, took it either
from the wild, or from a nursery,
set it aside, cut away
its top root so all
that was left are the feeder roots.
And from that that point on the tree
needs a person to take care of it
for the rest of its life.
We'll all be talking about
this in our various talks,
but it's really one of the
great treasures about a bonsai
because these trees live
for hundreds of years,
and it means that there's a constant
sequence of people who take care
of them through that time.
When you think about it, this living
off its feeder roots is really
something, because a tree in
nature could have tens of feet --
hundreds of feet of area of roots.
But in -- if you look at it, this
is reduced to just a small pot.
And that's why it's so important
for humans to pay close attention
to the trees that they're caring
for when they're a bonsai.
The great thing about
having the bonsai Museum
at the Arboretum is you
can find large versions
of the small trees right outside.
And here's a Japanese white pine,
really at the front door
the Museum at the Arboretum.
You'll walk through an
alley of cryptomeria,
which is just what you
would do if you were
in Japan visiting a
shrine or a temple.
And it's, again, another way of
leaving the daily cares and worries
of your life outside, in this
case, you're leaving them
in the grounds of the Arboretum.
You enter into the museum area.
And it gives you a chance to
kind of reflect and, you know,
lose yourself in the
beauty of the moment.
The museum is set up in a Japanese
style to honor the gift of trees
in 1976; so that was
a choice they made.
The entrance, as you can
see, is a Japanese --
well this is the inner
part of the museum.
And like any museum, it's
set up in rooms and spaces,
many of which don't
have roofs or ceilings,
because these are living works
of art, and they need to have --
they need to experience sun, rain,
you know, snow to a certain extent.
And most of the year, there
will be a tree on display,
just as you can see this
gingko through the gate.
And that means that there is a
tree that the person in charge,
the curator or the bonsai master,
feels is particularly noteworthy.
So when you go the museum,
which I hope you will,
do check out the tree
that's on view there.
So how all this started, as Mari
said, was with a gift from Japan
in 1976 to honor the
bicentennial of the United States.
But actually it started in 1975
when this picture was taken,
when it shows the Japanese dignitary
handing the American ambassador
at the time, the paperwork
that made the gift official.
And the reason it was a year in
advance is that the trees needed
to be in quarantine for a year.
And so this was all
happening in Tokyo in Japan.
The tree on view is tree number one,
and the reason it was tree number
one, it's a Japanese black pine,
but they thought at the time that
it had been in training since 1776,
which would make it the same
age as the United States.
They found out later that it's only
been in training only since 1895.
[Laughter] So it's -- but
it's still tree number one,
even though it's not as
old as the United States.
There were 53 trees, and 51
for each state, and then three
from the Imperial Household.
When the emperor and his
family learned what was afoot,
they wanted to be part of it.
So there were 50 trees from
the government and three trees
from the Imperial Household,
and this is one of them.
It's a Japanese red pine.
And don't you love
that zigzag trunk?
I think it's really extraordinary.
It's one of a pair.
The other one is in the
Imperial Household in Japan.
It's been in training since 1795.
It's huge.
Bonsai can be as small as my thumb,
or more typically, about this big.
But they can be also as --
this is almost as large
as I am, maybe larger.
And of course, for
the Imperial Palace,
which has big spaces,
you'd need bigger trees.
But it's still smaller than if
you experienced a tree like this,
particularly of that
age that -- in the wild.
So here's a funny story
about that tree.
The Emperor Hirohito and his wife
came to the United States in 1975.
And the one thing the emperor
wanted to do was visit the tree.
And of course, an itinerary
for an emperor is not going
to include enough time to
go out to suburban Maryland,
which is where the
tree was in quarantine.
So they had to find a way
to get the tree to him,
and they had to find a way to do
it so that it wasn't going to be
around any other plant material.
So of course, you know, getting it
into a truck is no problem, and,
you know, getting the truck
to the White House was no
problem; but then what?
Well, somehow they found either a
back staircase, or some private way
to get the tree up to the
Ford's private residence.
And that's where this picture
is taken with President
and Mrs. Ford meeting
with the emperor
and the empress with the tree.
And I'd like to think that if
the -- if it was a White House --
if it was a Department of
Agriculture photographer,
their tree would be more prominent.
[Laughter] But anyway,
it's there, it's proof,
and we know that it all happened.
In 1975, the Japanese Suiseki
Society also gave this beautiful
viewing stone.
And you'll find a collection of
viewing stones at the Museum.
I bring it up just so if you go to
the Museum, you're not surprised.
But I also think they're
associated very closely with bonsai,
because what these are, these are
rocks found in nature that, again,
take a big idea and
show it in a small way.
And there's this kind of magical
quality, for lack of a better word.
In this case, the crystals in the
rock look like chrysanthemums,
and the color of the rock
make it look like, you know,
a full moon night in the fall.
And so if you think about it, if you
were going to have something like --
experience something like this in
the wild, a garden would be huge,
much bigger than a rock, this big.
And not only that, we're
looking at this picture in April,
and you wouldn't see chrysanthemums
blooming until October.
So again, it's a way
to experience --
to take yourself out of your
daily life, you know, be expanded,
have a change, a transformation,
if you will,
in your mind and in your heart.
So back to Tokyo.
The trees were put on view
for everyone to say goodbye
to before they came
to the United States.
And here's one of the oldest tree
-- well the oldest tree, on view.
And you can see the Japanese fellow
just in awe of how old it was
when he realized what it was.
This took place in Ueno
Park, for those of you
who are familiar with Tokyo.
And everyone knew that
this tree was very old,
but no one knew its real story
until this gentleman turned
up at the Museum in 2001
and told an amazing story,
which Sandy's book talks
about in more detail.
So hold on, and she'll take over.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Sandra Moore: Good morning.
I'm the author of a book for
children that adults can also enjoy,
but it's primarily a book for young
audiences called, "The Peace Tree
From Hiroshima: The Little
Bonsai with a Big Story."
And my connection to the
bonsai world really began
when I took a fall tour of
the Arboretum with a curator,
then curator Jack Sustic.
And I saw how delighted the
children were by the koi fish
in the reflecting pool,
and how charmed they were
by the small colorful bonsai
trees; this was in the fall.
And oh as Ann was saying, you know,
what delights us and is, you know,
informative to us about
seeing a bonsai is
that we can see the whole tree,
which we can't do in nature.
But for children, it's
especially exciting to be bigger
than a tree, you know, after all.
And most of the bonsai in the
Arboretum's collection could fit
on a child's school desk.
So I had a feeling that there was
children's book magic in the air.
[ Background Sounds ]
While I was impressed by the
incredible variety of bonsai
that masters from China
and North America had
in the Arboretum's collection, I
was really smitten by the trees
in the Japanese Pavilion, because
there were so many stories,
fascinating stories connected
to each of the trees.
The two here are a gingko,
which you can see on the right,
and then the trident maple on the
left, and they had been planted
and sculpted by bonsai masters
for well over a hundred years.
The trident maple on the
right was a gift from a member
of the royal family and has
been in training since 1896.
Although, the final stop on the
tour -- it was building up to this,
was really the crown jewel
and the oldest resident
in the Arboretum, the Yamaki pine.
The Yamaki pine is named after
the family that donated it.
And this magnificent white pine is
actually quite large for a bonsai,
with a wide and deeply-grooved
trunk.
The curator was clearly
fond of it, Jack was,
and delighted to share
its life story with us.
First, he explained that the tree
had been in training since 1625.
Wow. Most Americans, I
think, consider themselves
to have a green thumb
if they're able
to keep a potted plant alive
for three years, maybe?
But the idea of keeping a tree alive
for 350 years is just unheard of.
But the Yamaki family
had that distinction.
And it occurred to me -- oh let's
see, there's the -- this is the --
sorry, the plaque that's
underneath the white pine.
And it is mostly referred to as the
Yamaki pine in honor of the family,
but it's also sometimes
known by its name,
part of the scientific
name "Miyagima."
It occurred to me that this tree
is amazing witness to history,
from the days of samurai
and castles in Japan,
to the age of modern cell phones
in America, it's seen it all.
The Yamaki pine was also cared for
by one family for five generations.
And the illustrator of my book,
Kazumi Wilds, you can se here
in this illustration,
did a great job
of showing how the care-giving
was passed down from father to son
from the Edo period,
until in the 1970s.
And the family would later provide
me with a genealogical chart
that had all the names
of their ancestors.
So we could use names
like "Itaro" and "Yajiro,"
who are their ancestors
in our story.
Perhaps the most amazing and
shocking thing that I learned
that day was that the Yamaki
pine was a Hiroshima survivor.
The Yamaki pine, the bonsai, was on
the porch of Masaru Yamaki's house
in Hiroshima in 1945, and
survived the atomic bombing,
though it was only two
miles from ground zero.
This photo shows Mr.
Yamaki being interviewed,
probably by Japanese
radio reporters.
He was well-known as a master
bonsai artist, and of course,
after the stories that we're talking
about, the impact on families
and all the deaths, there were also
concerns about these special trees.
This is Mr. Yamaki.
And this is on the occasion of
his visit to the United States.
All of the donors of the
bonsai were given a free trip
to the United States.
Unfortunately, he had been ill.
By 1979, three years after the
donation, he was able to come.
And one of the things that moved me
about the story was how
devoted his family was to it,
as if the tree were really
a member of their family.
The curator told us one
anecdote that I'd like to share
that demonstrated the
strong connection
between the Japanese family
and this beloved tree.
When Mr. Yamaki came to visit,
the story goes that he came
in a black limousine, and
he toured the collection.
He was with hosts from
the Arboretum.
But then he stopped in front of the
white pine, and his hosts noticed
that he had tears in his eyes.
And of course, you know,
they were worried, you know,
"Is there something
we've done wrong?"
And the translator asked Mr.
Yamaki, "Is everything all right?"
And in just a moment's time, you
know, after pausing, he said,
"Oh, yes, everything's fine.
These are tears of
joy because I can see
that my tree is happy
here in its new home."
Phew. [Laughter] I share this
story with everyone I knew,
and it never failed
to make an impression.
And I think that was
really the moment
when I decided I was determined to
turn it into a story for children.
First I knew I needed to be in
touch with the Yamaki family.
And fortunately, I had a
friend Chisou [phonetic],
who was a reporter at Reuters, and
she and a native Japanese speaker,
she helped me translate my
letters to the Yamaki's.
And, you know, I was asking them,
"May I tell your tree story?"
In response, I received an e-mail
from Yasuo Yamaki, actually his son.
And his son wrote me an e-mail, and
the e-mail said, "It is a delight
that the Yamaki pine
attracts public attention.
I think my grandfather
must rejoice in heaven."
So of course, I put this note on
my bulletin board to motivate me
as I searched for a publisher
that would share my
enthusiasm for this tree story.
In March of 2014, I received
word from an editor in Singapore
that Tuttle Publishing
would produce my book.
I was, of course, delighted.
And then the next thing, as
a children's book author,
you are always really
anxious to find
out who they would choose
to illustrate your book.
And I felt strongly,
and as did Tuttle,
that we needed a Japanese
illustrator to ensure
that the book was culturally
sensitive and authentic.
I wanted someone who
had been to the places
that we would be writing about, that
had sensitivities about the war.
And that person, fortunately for
me, turned out to be Kazumi Wilds.
Kazumi had actually lived in
the States for a short time,
but she was living
in Japan at the time.
And in a stroke of good luck,
she was just beginning a graduate
program in the United States
in Iowa, and that meant that
she could come to Washington.
So she came and stayed
with my family.
And the first job was to
meet the tree, as she said,
"I need to meet the tree."
And then she looked at photographs
in the Arboretum's archives,
and toured Washington, all
things that she needed to do,
and things she needed to sketch
so that when she returned home --
or actually when she returned
back to Iowa, in this case,
she could begin the paintings
that would become the
book's illustrations.
This is one of the
illustrations from the book as well
of Masaru Yamaki as he's
saying goodbye to Miyajima.
I wanted the book to be about
reconciliation and peace.
And the significance of the Yamaki's
gift is that it demonstrates
that peace is really
built between people long
after the peace treaties are signed.
And answers the question
-- I wanted it
to answer a question I
sometimes ask children which is,
"How do you make friends
with someone
after you have been enemies?"
Mr. Yamaki chose to make a
peace offering with not just one
of his very large collection
of bonsai trees, but, you know,
what his family said
was really his favorite,
and the oldest in his collection.
But given the tree's history,
we could not skirt the fact
that America and Japan
had been in a bitter war.
And somehow, you know, I had
had to think about that a lot
when I was writing the text,
and then it became the challenge
for Kazumi, the illustrator,
how to portray the atomic
bombing in a book for children.
As I'm sure, you know,
many of you are familiar,
there are so many images, many of
them that would be really disturbing
or frightening to a young audience,
so we had to be very careful.
This, from the Library
of Congress's archives,
is a photo that I'm sure you're
all familiar with of the dome
that survived, the "Peace Dome"
it's now often referred to,
and it's part of the Hiroshima
Peace Memorial Museum.
That actually is shown in
the very distance in one
of the illustrations of our book.
Out of the 32 pages in the
book, just four are devoted
to the Hiroshima chapter
of the tree's life.
And in this image, which is
difficult, but I think gentle
as we could be in a
book for children,
Kazumi shows Hiroshima
reduced to rubble.
And she chose, you know,
two images in particular
that she thought children
would resonate with,
which is there's a little
dog in the lower part
of the illustration, and a tricycle.
It's followed, the
next page in the story,
by a picture that shows
Masaru bowing in gratitude
because his family and their
beloved bonsai were spared.
As the reviewer for the Kids Post,
The Washington Kids Post said,
"In her art, Wilds doesn't show the
horrible details of the bombing.
Instead she uses darker colors
to set a sad, quiet tone,"
which you can see in this
illustration, "and brighter colors
to reveal hope as the
city recovers."
This beautiful illustration,
probably my favorite from the book,
shows postwar Hiroshima,
and is full of hope
and spirit, and cosmos flowers.
The painting sets the stage
for a much happier chapter
in the tree's life at
the National Arboretum.
As our story comes to an
close, Mr. Yamaki arrives
at the Arboretum, as
he did in real life.
But in our story, he is
accompanied by his grandson.
We were pretty much slavishly
attached to the true story
in our book, which is, you
know, about 99% nonfiction.
And but the one way in which we
change things is that we used --
he actually has a grandson
that's named "Akira,"
and that's the name
of the character here.
And Akira now is in I think his
maybe late 20s, and he also --
and there was a photo in the
beginning that Ann showed you
of him visiting the Arboretum.
But I wanted to have a
young character in the book,
so we have Akira coming with
his grandfather as a young boy.
And as you can see in
this final illustration,
he is giving his family's
tree a loving pat.
Our book was published seven decades
after the bombing of Hiroshima.
And I think it has special resonance
now because we're at a time
when reconciliation and peace
between our two countries
continues to deepen.
This was evident when Barack Obama
became the first American president
to visit the Hiroshima
Peace Memorial.
And like the gentleman who is
embraced by Obama in this photo,
the Yamaki pine is a Hiroshima
survivor, and has contributed
in its own small way to the
process of reconciliation and peace.
And when I share this book with
children, they seem to understand
and appreciate the significance
of the tree as a peace symbol.
And I'd like to turn the podium over
to Stephen, who found great peace
in photographing the bonsai.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Stephen Voss: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I am thrilled to be here.
I want to thank everyone at the
Library of Congress and Mari
for all your help in
making this work.
So my name is Stephen Voss.
And I am a photographer here in DC,
and make my living mostly
shooting portraits of people,
actually spending a lot of
time in this area with a lot
of politicians doing
that sort of work.
And I've done this
work for a long time.
I have -- and, you know, I've always
sort of had a personal project
on the side, something I did when I
wasn't doing my professional work.
And a couple years ago, I had just
finished this personal project
where I had walked the entire border
of DC, the 40 or so miles sort
of meeting people, photographing
people and trying to, you know,
understand my city in a way.
And as I had finished that
up, I started to think
about what's the next
thing I wanted to do?
And at the time I had
some frustrations
with my professional work.
When you shoot portraits
of people, you know,
you want to make a connection.
You want to do something
that, you know, it is --
get a response out
of them, you know,
have them reveal something
of themselves.
And what you find in
Washington often is that,
you know, people are busy.
So often, you know, you
schedule a time you're going
to photograph someone, you think
you're going to have 30 minutes,
and then in one example -- and
this is the one I always come back
to is I had an appointment to
photograph Mikhail Gorbachev,
which I was very excited about,
I was looking forward to;
we got in there three hours
early, set everything up,
and then before I knew it, we
were being told that we were done.
And I looked at it, I
had shot eight frames,
and I had had all of
90 seconds with him.
[Laughter] And so I was
-- this is frustrating.
And so as I started to think about,
"What is the next thing
I want to do?
What's my personal project next,"
I thought of the bonsai museum.
And I had known about this
collection for a long time.
When I went to school
here, I used to visit it.
I've had a few bonsai of my own,
which have all met their
untimely demise at my hands.
And so I thought about
that question.
I thought, "Let me go have a look.
I'm not sure what's going to
happen, but let me go out there
and see what I can find."
And so this first image from my book
is of the Japanese white pine that,
you know, we've all
been talking about,
one of the most stunning
trees in the collection.
And I encourage you
-- you know, the --
we're not that far from
the Arboretum here.
It really is -- if you
haven't been there,
now is a really wonderful
time to go in the spring
when things are starting
to bloom and blossom.
And so I would go to the
Arboretum on days I wasn't working,
wander around for a little bit,
and try to find a tree that,
you know, on that day spoke to me.
And, you know, what these
trees gave me was time.
You know, I could spend as
much time as I want with them.
I could appraise them
fully, stand before them,
no constraints, no one walking out.
And, you know, the bonsai seemed
like the opposites of the subjects
that I usually photographed.
They stand before me fully
present, and, you know,
their sense of time is measured in
decades, even centuries, you know,
not minutes, and I love that.
So when I stand before these
trees, you know, I see the trees,
but what I really started to see
after a while were the
people behind them.
Ann and Sandy have alluded to this,
but these trees not self-sufficient
once they become bonsai.
You know, they need
care every single day.
And you think about a bonsai
master who makes a tree
like this his or her life's work.
They put everything into this tree,
but knowing that at some point
this tree is going to outlive them;
it's going to be passed
onto someone else.
And this work of art that they
have created is now going to be
in the hands of someone else.
And I love that there's
something very hopeful
to me about that, you know.
a belief in the future, a belief
that this tree will
continue to exist past you.
And also I think there's
this great sense of empathy,
of letting go of your work
and letting someone
else take control of it.
And those are the things that,
you know, as you spend time
with these trees, I think these
things will reveal themselves
to you.
And so these trees became
sort of this window into all
of that history, you know,
a connection between
events a hundred years ago
and you standing right
in front of that tree.
So what I was looking for was a
way in for each tree, you know,
a way to sort of understand
the tree, to photograph it
in a way that felt meaningful.
Early on, I -- you know, as I
began photographing these trees
and going back and back, I had a
lot of doubts about this project.
I had a lot of doubts about
the value of these photos.
Part of me was concerned that this
was not so dissimilar to going
to a museum and taking a
photograph of a painting.
Like, you know, it's kind of
like a fully-formed piece of art.
Like what would I bring to it?
And that was, you know, just sort
of the things that I was churning
over in my head as I
began this project and,
you know, kept photographing them.
And what I realized -- you
know, it took a long time,
but what I realized as I
stood before these trees is
that it was not my job
to document them, per se.
What really felt important to me was
to capture something of the spirit
of them, what it felt
like to be near them.
And this sort of little bit of a
conversation you'd have with a tree
when you spend enough
time in front of it
where it would reveal something
to you, you'd kind of start
to see the sort of invisible hands
of the bonsai masters who worked
on it and all the little
decisions they made
that made the tree what it is today.
And, you know, it's remarkable to
see -- when you go to the arboretum,
sometimes, you can see people
working on these trees.
And they make these cuts,
these decisions the way they
wire the branches in anticipation
of something that might not
really happen for a year,
five years, even ten years.
And I love that scale of time
to be thinking about things
in those terms, instead of sort
of the, you know, minute to minute
that we often live our lives.
And so I kept going back to
the collection, you know,
as the seasons change,
the leaves emerge.
This was -- this crape myrtle,
I think this photo was taken
almost exactly two years ago.
And just to go back to
one of my original places,
now is a great time to visit.
The leaves are just starting
to emerge on the trees,
and it's a really beautiful time
where you can still see
the underlying, you know,
structure of the tree, but you can
also start to appreciate the color
and the growth that they
have at this time of year.
So at this point, I had made about
a hundred trips to the Arboretum,
and I've taken about 12,000 images.
And at that point, you know,
I realized that this personal
project maybe was something more
than just a personal project; maybe
something else could come of it.
And I started -- you know,
I talked with colleagues,
started editing these photos
down, and realized that, you know,
maybe there was a book in this.
And so I worked with the
designer and made this book.
And, you know, when
I share this book,
it's a way of me sharing my
gratitude for this place,
sharing my impression of this place,
and hopefully trying to pass on some
of the gift it gave
me to other people.
And I think when you look at these,
you know, trees they kind of --
they speak their own language.
You sort of -- I don't know, the
more time you spend with them,
the more you understand
where they're from.
And so one of the really
great pleasures of this book,
it's a book about 85 photos or so.
And I was also able to go into
the archives of the Arboretum
of the Bonsai Museum and look and
see where these trees came from.
And it's remarkable some of these
beautiful magnificent trees what
humble beginnings they had.
There's a, you know, blue atlas
cedar that I think was found growing
in a coffee can in
the back of a nursery.
And it was bought for five dollars.
And another tree was found along the
side of a highway, and, you know,
someone, they pulled over, grabbed
it, and, you know, with the --
I think one of the gifts of a
bonsai master is to see potential,
you know, see that maybe
this isn't a bonsai tree now,
but maybe ten years,
20 years down the road,
this is going to be
a magnificent tree.
And so one thing I really
wanted to include in this book
in the back sort of as appendix
was a little bit about this tree
that I photographed, about its past,
its history, and where it came from.
So I went on this image;
this image was --
I chose as the cover of the book.
And I love this image.
It sort of kind of distills
to me like my favorite photos
of these trees are
somewhat abstract.
The trees in some ways become
something else more than just,
you know, a tree, but they also --
you can sort of appreciate the
ancientness of these living things.
And one thing that was
pointed out to me that I loved
that I didn't realize at the time is
if you take the shape of this tree,
the curve of it, and you
overlay it on a map of Japan,
it fits almost perfectly.
[Laughter] And I thought
that was just a wonderful bit
of serendipity that I love about it.
And so in closing, I just --
I want to share something that I had
written as a foreword to this book.
And I wrote, "If I'm able
to share anything of my time
or on the bonsai, it is the
grace and the passage of time,
their peace, and the invitation
they extend to include one's self
in the natural order of things."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ann McClellan: So just
shifting gears just a little bit,
here we are back in 1972 when
Richard Nixon went to China.
And as you can see in the photo,
there is a Penjing
in the background.
As I mentioned earlier, the practice
of Penjing, could also be called
"bonsai," had been practiced
in China for thousands
of years, a thousand years anyway.
And it was one of the art forms that
moved to Japan along with things
like calligraphy, the tea
ceremony, Zen Buddhism.
But it was continued to be practiced
in China throughout all that time.
But then in more recent turbulent
history in the Chinese world,
most of the specimens were lost.
So they are not examples of
hundreds of years old Penjing
in China the way there
are of bonsai in Japan.
However, you can see that in 1972
when President Nixon when to China
and is toasting [inaudible],
they had a Penjing in the room.
And I think that it -- who
knows where it came from;
it was obviously important to them.
I think it was used in the same way
that we used flower arrangements
to adorn special occasions.
And we know that Richard
Nixon was given three Penjing
when he left China.
We don't know what happened to
them; they're no longer existing.
But the whole idea of using them
as diplomatic gifts was
something the Chinese did,
as well as the Japanese.
So the Chinese version of
bonsai is a little different;
it's a little looser, slightly
less geometric, a little less --
maybe in one word would
be "refined."
And the other thing is it's
a little more directive.
As you can see in this picture,
it's a Pauper's tea tree,
and there's a little figure.
That's a philosopher
scholar in the bottom.
And so it's suggesting to you
to put yourself in the spot
of the philosopher scholar.
Remember, the Japanese
ones we've seen
so far don't typically
have a figure,
so you can use your
imagination to interact
with the tree as you would like.
But this one's a little
more directive.
And I think a poem
from the 8th century
in China speaks to
it, so here it goes.
It's from the Chinese
poet, Wang Wei.
"I sit alone in a bamboo grove,
strumming on my loot
while singing a song.
In the deep forest, no
one knows I am here.
Only the bright moon
comes to shine on me."
Don't you think that fits
with that picture; that tree?
This one there is no figure.
But again you get that looser style.
This was styled by Dr. Woo, who was
the donor who gave the original gift
of Chinese Penjing that makes
the Museum Bonsai in Penjing.
He was a banker in Hong Kong.
He had a fabulous collection,
several museums have examples
of it, but we do here too.
And here's an interesting thing.
This is an image from the Freer.
And you can really see how the
two arts relate to each other.
Isn't that amazing?
You could just picture that
female figure easily transposed
onto the tree.
So it's -- while there are
connections in Japanese art,
it's much stronger in Chinese
art to see this connection
between the two-dimensional
and the three-dimensional.
This one is a huge tray,
was designed in 2004
by the then director of the
Shanghai Botanical Garden.
And again, you get those
old, wizened, you know,
gnarly-looking trees,
rocks, little figures.
And here's an example.
This happens to be on a fan,
but it's a scroll-type painting.
And you can see the rocks, the
trees; there's a little house.
But it's the same notion.
Penjing doesn't have to have plant
material; it can be rocks only.
Can't you just see that dragon
coming up from the Earth?
[Makes Sound] [Laughter]
But it also --
you have a dragon form
in plant material.
Jack Sustic, the curator we've
all been talking about said this,
"You'd only find this in a museum."
And I think what he means
is this is a lot of work.
And at the museum, there are people
doing bonsai all day every day,
seven days a week.
And to maintain this figure
requires that kind of constant,
constant care and clipping.
This was designed by Stanley Chin,
a Chinese American, who was renowned
for doing really extraordinary works
of art, and this is a great example.
This is perhaps the most famous
bonsai in the collection.
It's actually from North American.
It's designed by John Naka.
It's called "Goshen," which
means "protector of the spirit."
These are Chinese junipers.
And where you get the
illusion of age is
in the wild the trees are zapped
by lightning, which kills the tops,
and then the middle part of the
foliage continues to survive.
There are 11 trees
in this forest grove,
and one for each of
his grandchildren.
The wider ones are in the front, and
the narrower ones are in the rear.
So it gives you the
illusion of great depth.
So it's -- I've seen people
who just stand there, you know,
mesmerized by imagining
themselves in the middle
of this grove; it's
quite astonishing.
Here is a picture of John Naka
with it, which I'm showing both
for scale, and also
please notice the foliage.
The foliage in this case --
this photo might have been taken
at this time of year where there's
new growth, so it's kind of,
you know, a little bit
scruffy, or it could be
that that's how the bonsai master
in charge at the time preferred
to see foliage; whereas this
picture, this bonsai master wants it
to be more firm, if
you will, more solid.
There's nothing right or
wrong about either of these.
That's just -- that's a
choice, and that's part
of what we've been talking about,
how these trees live for hundreds
of years, so they can -- and they're
living works of art so they change.
This is one of my personal
favorites.
It's a ponderosa pine
designed by Dan Robinson,
a Pacific Northwestern
American bonsai artist.
It was a gift from the US
Forest Service to the arboretum
on the occasion of the Forest
Service's 75h anniversary.
Now, what's -- there are
two things about this tree.
First of all, this is the view
that the artist wants you to see.
And every bonsai has a view that
the artists wants you to see.
It's like, you know, Stephen taking
a photograph, that's the view.
Sometimes there can be more views.
And in this case, the tree is, you
know, roundish, square-ish, biggish.
And from 360 degrees,
there's something of interest.
So they frequently put it on
display in a place that you can walk
around and see all those views.
So if you have a chance to see it,
do do that because it
changes dramatically.
The other thing I love about this is
to me it expresses the Western,
I don't know, character.
And I could just see it's almost
like a guy walking
into a bar, you know.
[Makes Sound] [Laughter] And in fact
I was just out at the Arboretum.
The tree was on view and I
was asking how it was doing.
"Oh, that's tree's fine.
It takes everything we throw at it."
[Laughter] This one is a California
juniper designed by Harry Hirao,
who is another Japanese American.
He and John Naka both were the
people who were among those
who were very strong and promoting
bonsai as a study for people
who are not Japanese and
here in the United States.
Harry Hirao is no longer
with us, unfortunately,
but a lot of his work is at
the Huntington in Pasadena.
What's unusual about this tree is
the bottom looks completely dead,
doesn't it?
I mean, you can't even believe that
there's that foliage at the top.
And the lifeline, I don't
know if you can see,
but there's a little brown
line just on the edge,
and that is where the water
and nutrients go from the base
to the foliage at the top.
Now, this tree you can look at the
silhouette, and you can imagine it
from the rear, it would also
be interesting; you know,
turned around, it would
be interesting.
But if you looked at
it from the side,
it would be about as
interesting as a Fig Newton.
That doesn't make it less beautiful
than the one I just showed you,
it's just this is just
a different approach.
This tree is by Vaughn Banting from
Louisiana, and it's a bald Cyprus.
It started out life as
a Christmas tree shape,
and over years he pruned it
and encouraged it to grow
so that it would look like
an ancient bald Cyprus
like the one photo on the right,
with no limbs on the lower part,
limbs reaching up to the light on
the top, and then it has a knee.
Now, what are those knees for?
Well, if you think about, trees
breathe through their roots
in addition to their
leaves, if they have them.
And if you're a bald Cyprus,
what are you going to do
if your feet are, you know,
up to your ankles in water?
You lift up your knee and the air
can come through the roots that way.
So that's what the roots are
about, and I think it's neat
that he put one into the bonsai.
Here's that zigzag trunk again.
This is a bougainvillea.
And it proves that any tree with
a woody stem can be a bonsai.
The other thing I'd like to
point out about this image is
that this shows clearly that the
bonsai master has put this tree
on formal display.
And for formal display,
it's like putting someone
in their wedding clothes.
You know, the trees clip to a never
do well [phonetic] and, you know,
there's no little stray
little, you know, twigs,
or dead pieces, or anything.
The tipoff for when you see
a tree that's on a rocky slab
like this one, or if it's on a
raised tray, something like that,
that's the clue that this
is on formal display.
If you see the tree is just lined up
on a counter, or even on a pedestal,
but if they're not with
the rock slab or tray,
that shows they're just,
you know, there to be seen.
Often also they will make sure that
the moss is especially beautiful
for a tree that's on formal display.
So when you see a tree like that,
pay attention because that
means the bonsai master feels
that this tree is in tiptop
shape, it's one of those minutes
in its long, long life
when it's, you know,
worthy of your close
attention, and he hopes that --
he or she hopes that
you will take a look.
So thank you very much
for coming today.
We'd love to answer any questions.
And we hope you've enjoyed this,
you know, sort of round the world
and from three different
people [laughter] in the world
of bonsai here in Washington.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
Oh, surely someone has a question.
[Laughter] No?
>> I'd just like to mention --
>> Ann McClellan: Yes.
>> That the festival is
coming up at the museum.
And I think Stephen
was there last year.
Do you know the dates
this year, May 14th, 15th?
>> Ann McClellan: It's
Saturday, May 14th or 15th.
But yes it is coming right,
and we'll all be there.
>> Right; we're open on Sunday.
>> The arboretum is very close.
>> Ann McClellan: Right.
>> Yes. [Laughter]
We'll be there, and lots
of other people doing lots
of other things too.
>> Right.
>> Ann McClellan: Yes.
Thank you.
Anybody else?
Yes.
>> That was certainly fascinating.
Thank you very much.
I was wondering if you could say
something about the training process
and particularly how
the shapes are created.
>> Ann McClellan: Yes; the question
is how are the shapes created?
And actually there are
several different ways.
Sometimes -- most often
today they use wire.
They trim and then they help the
new growth by using wire to shape it
in the way that they want it to go.
Do you remember that wonderful
tree that Stephen showed you
where it looks like all the
limbs are going back that way?
Well, actually how that started,
it was a Stanley Chin creation.
And when Jack Sustic got it, it
had that wonderful curving trunk,
remember that, but all
the limbs were like this,
so they're like a little triangle.
And Jack thought, "How could
I make this more interesting?
I can make the limbs go this way."
And he did it by wiring them
so that they'd all go that way.
And you get that breathtaking
effect.
The other thing to do
is what's called "clip
and grow" that's more
typically used by the Chinese
so that the trees are
trimmed, as opposed to wired.
And the way I think about penjing
versus bonsai is it's
like calligraphy.
You know, if you have block
print, you can read the sentence,
but if you have it in copper plate,
you can also read the sentence.
So it's -- you know, they're not --
they're in the same
bracket that way,
just sort of different
ways of treating it.
And it's similarly with
the training, you know,
they use the wires in Japan and
here in the States, but then clip
and grow is more typical in China.
Thank you for your question.
Anybody else?
Yes? Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Thank you.
>> Well, my question, which
is related to this one.
>> Ann McClellan: Yes.
>> What kind of fertilizer
or, you know, mulch,
or nutrition [inaudible]?
>> Ann McClellan: That's
a good question.
The question is what kind of mulch
or fertilizer is typically used?
And the answer is it
depends on the tree.
I just asked that the other
day when I was out there,
because when you see them, some of
them have what looks like teabags
on their bases, other ones have
pellets, others have nothing.
And so they use particular
planting material for some trees
that is enough nutrients
for the tree.
Others need different supplements.
And so it really depends
on the type of tree,
and makes all the difference
actually.
Because when you think about it,
if you have just this much space
to get all your nutrients as opposed
to acres, it's really essential
that you get the right mix.
So it varies from variety
to variety.
Great question; yes, thank you.
>> Yes. I can just add to that
that it's very interesting,
one of the bonsai masters
that was responsible
for getting the Brooklyn Botanical
Gardens their first bonsai tree
in the 1950s, he has actually
regularly talked to his trees;
like that was part of the care.
And when you read about bonsai
masters, that's one of the things
that you find out that, you
know, some of them, you know,
it's much more of a -- they feel
like they really do have a
relationship with the tree.
And I think the quote that I
saw in his obituary was he said,
"If you listen carefully
to the tree,
it will tell you what it needs."
>> Ann McClellan: Aw.
>> Now, so I'm not sure that the
tree would tell you, you know,
what kind of, you know, fertilizer,
exactly, [laughter] but certainly
if it needs more light,
or if it needs more sun,
you know, that might be something.
>> Ann McClellan: Right.
>> Yes.
>> Ann McClellan: Okay, thank you.
Yes.
>> Well, hearing that I would like
to ask Stephen, you felt that kind
of conversation where you are trying
to capture the picture
of the bonsai?
>> Stephen Voss: Yes;
I definitely felt
like I had conversations
with the trees.
And I think, you know, this book and
these photos are sort of in praise
of like taking time, like spending
a lot of time with one tree,
standing before it and
having that give and take.
And, you know, I would often go to
the Arboretum and be unsuccessful,
you know, and photograph a tree
and it just would not work out,
and that would be a
failed conversation.
[Laughs] So, you know, my hope was
with each tree to have that sort
of point where I feel like I
understood this tree in a way
and I can make a photo to
express that understanding.
>> Ann McClellan: Please; yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Thank you.
>> I have a question.
So all [inaudible] that you
showed us screens by the --
care by professional bonsai
artists, or how you call "curator."
>> Ann McClellan: Yes.
>> Are there people
doing this as a hobby?
It sounds like it's a really, really
huge serious commitment every day.
And given the current society,
the time it took always busy,
and you don't really feel
like [inaudible] every day
for a long time to take
care of this bonsai?
If I want to do it as a
hobby, is it possible,
and is there any way to [inaudible]?
[Laughter]
>> Well, okay, I think
the question is --
but thank you, yes
it is a commitment
on the part of the curators.
Yes; there are lots of
hobbyists who do practice it.
There's the Potomac
Bonsai Association.
And yes most of the
people are older,
because they are the
people who have time.
But then there are younger
people who get into it
because it's extremely rewarding.
You know, you're creating
a living work of art,
and it's got the challenge,
the beauty of nature, you know,
it's a wonderful way to be
expressing your creativity.
And those people tend to have
assistance or someone, you know,
friends who can -- like a
group of people who will do it.
But you're right, I think
especially in Japan, I believe,
that it's not as popular as it used
to be, because people are busy, and,
you know, there's a
space issue, because,
you know, they need to be outside.
They can't just -- it's
not like, you know,
a house plant that can be
just stuck in a window.
And, you know, some of them,
a tropical bonsai could live
in a window, but most of them prefer
to be outside because
[overlapping] --
>> At World Bonsai Day, which
you were mentioning earlier,
which is coming up in
May at the Arboretum,
there are people there selling
bonsai, and many hobbyists there,
I think, who are, you know, excited
to -- you can hear people, you know,
sort of trading stories about, you
know, their experience, you know,
learning to raise bonsai.
And I think a number of the
nurseries in the area have someone
on staff who is more,
you know, experienced,
who can sort of give
you some guidance.
I know I have a bonsai tree, and
there's a Korean bonsai master,
Du Kee Hong [phonetic], who is
with Behnke's Nursery,
you know, for a while.
And so, you know, I would ask him
for advice if I was worried of,
you know, am I doing
the right thing?
But the -- you know, at the World
Bonsai Day, that's a good time
to come, because you can learn
about it if you were interested
in it as a hobby, you know?
>> May I respond to that, please.
>> Ann McClellan: Yes, of course.
>> I'm a member of two
of the local clubs.
>> Ann McClellan: Great.
>> Most of the members are retired.
However, there are some
young people who are joining.
For instance, the Northern Virginia
Bonsai Society there are 50 members,
and is growing.
[Laughs] The other club at Brookside
-- and they both have websites.
The Brookside Club has
-- it's a smaller group.
But we each gather at each
meeting and usually once a month,
and sometimes twice a month
and we help one another.
The more experienced and wonderful
curators of the Bonsai Museum
to use its member of Brookside Club.
And so his expertise
is always available,
and there are two fantastic experts
on the Northern Virginia club,
who are constantly
helping the junior members.
And we [inaudible] our trees.
We work on them, we wire them,
we [inaudible], we prune.
And we have other experts
come in who speak
and perhaps demonstrate
at the same time.
So we're constantly learning.
[Laughter]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Ann McClellan: Thank you.
>> Looks like it's almost
like a therapeutic process.
>> Oh, it's wonderful.
>> Ann McClellan: I
think so; I think so.
>> Yes.
>> Ann McClellan: I mean,
it's all encompassing really.
>> It takes you out into
nature even at your own home
when you're working on a tree.
>> Ann McClellan: That's a -- I'm
going to repeat that for the video,
it takes you out into
nature even when you're
in your own home, so yes.
>> Yes; even if you
have a little patio.
>> Ann McClellan: Even if
you have a little patio.
Thank you.
And yes, in the back?
>> Well, I noticed how
big some of them were.
>> Ann McClellan: Yes.
>> And my -- you mentioned
repotting, and that was my question.
How often how do you
have to repot them?
>> Ann McClellan: Well -
>> Can you keep them
small, you know --
>> Ann McClellan: Well, they
-- repotting doesn't mean --
it's not like a house plant that
you repot into something larger.
It goes back into either the
same pot, or if the curator
or bonsai master wants
to change the pot,
it's not going to be
to a bigger one.
So what happens is that
the tree gets removed.
And if -- you know, honestly for
that big imperial pon [phonetic],
that requires, you know,
slings of -- and a big --
you know, a good contraption to
lift up and take the pot away,
then they scrap away the excess
earth, they cut away a lot
of those feeder roots so that new
ones will grow, and replace it
with fresh potting material
that's specific to that tree.
And really, you know, it's
reduced I think almost by a third.
It depends on the tree.
But it's very -- it's very important
-- it's important to do it right,
and it's important to do
it when you're supposed to,
which varies from tree to tree.
I think the imperial pon
it's every, you know,
five years or something like that.
Some of the smaller trees
it might be more often.
But it depends on the variety
and how quickly their roots grow.
But if you're living -- I'm
talking as if I'm a tree,
if you're living just, you
know, on those feeder roots,
you need lots of fresh ones.
So that's, you know, why it has to
be repotted fairly often; you know,
more often, then you probably have
to do a houseplant
typically, I would think.
Yes. Well, these have
been questions.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Mari, and --
>> Mari Nakahara: Thank you.
>> Ann McClellan: Okay.
>> Mari Nakahara: I
want to wrap up quickly.
We have great resources.
We don't have any technical
material resources at the Library,
but I have experience to receive
a couple of the bonsai creations,
especially for the [inaudible] that
researchers continue to contact me
like for two years to
ask about [inaudible].
So I did some research.
But, you know, we also have a
Prints and Photographs division,
collections -- have other
collections in the Library.
So if you keep interested, you know,
please come back and
do some research.
And please join me in applauding
the three speakers, bonsai curators.
[Laughter] So you thank
you very much [inaudible].
>> Ann McClellan: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.